J'ai préparé des réponses, mais on est tous les trois là pour répondre, pour agrémenter.
Et aussi, sentez-vous libre, c'est aussi fait pour ça, ces temps de questions-réponses,
de rebondir sur celles qui ont été traitées et de poser d'autres questions suite aux réponses.
C'est très profitable et c'est aussi pour ça qu'on est ensemble sur place pour faciliter ce genre d'échange.
Donc, on va commencer sans plus tarder avec la première question.
Alors, je me suis permis d'en regrouper certaines qui étaient liées.
Donc, là où les premières qu'on va traiter, c'est faut-il nécessairement faire une différence entre la providence et les miracles ?
Quel rôle joue la providence de Dieu dans notre quotidien ?
Et est-ce qu'elle joue aussi un rôle chez les non-croyants, dans la vie des non-croyants ?
Donc, on préférerait parler de distinction plutôt que de différence.
S'il faut faire une distinction, du coup, entre providence et miracle.
Car la providence et les miracles ont des différences, c'est certain, on va le voir.
Mais ils ont surtout la même source qui est Dieu et qui reste Dieu.
Excuse-moi, c'est quoi la providence ?
Ben, on va y venir.
T'inquiète pas, je vais donner des définitions.
Là, c'est juste une introduction.
Donc, dans les deux cas, providence et miracle, il s'agit d'une intervention de Dieu dans sa création.
Mais cette intervention, elle peut se faire de manière différente.
Et donc, le terme même de providence, et on va le définir dans quelques instants, il existe précisément pour faire cette distinction sur les différentes manières dont Dieu intervient dans sa création.
Soit de manière providentielle, soit de manière miraculeuse.
Les interventions miraculeuses de Dieu dans sa création, elles sont par définition des interventions qui sont directes, qui n'ont pas d'intermédiaire et qui sont surnaturelles.
C'est-à-dire qu'elles passent au-dessus, elles outrepassent ou elles font malgré, elles suspendent pour un temps les lois de la nature que Dieu a créées et instaurées.
Ça, c'est les interventions miraculeuses, les miracles que Dieu fait dans sa création.
Et il y a aussi les interventions providentielles, donc dans le cadre de la providence, qui sont aussi des interventions de Dieu dans sa création,
mais où cette fois-ci, il va utiliser des intermédiaires qui peuvent être très variés.
Ça peut être des événements météorologiques, des animaux, des hommes, des activités humaines comme la médecine, la science.
En fait, tout élément qui est présent dans sa création.
Mais cette fois-ci, en respectant les lois naturelles que Dieu a créées et mises en place.
Donc l'usage commun, la nature de ces choses que Dieu va utiliser.
Ça, ce sont les interventions providentielles de Dieu.
L'intervention dans sa création, mais en utilisant des intermédiaires,
qu'on appelle, que David a souvent mentionné comme cause seconde,
et en respectant cette fois-ci les lois naturelles.
Et contrairement au miracle, en n'allant pas au-dessus ou malgré ces lois naturelles.
Donc pour vous donner un exemple.
Biblique.
Lorsque Jésus envoie un de ses disciples pour chercher un âne pour son entrée à Jérusalem,
ou un âne, on va dire un âne pour simplifier l'exemple.
Et que le disciple qui part chercher cet âne le trouve exactement là où Jésus l'a décrit.
Et comme Jésus l'a décrit, c'est la providence de Dieu.
Mais lorsque Dieu parle à travers un âne,
je n'ai pas noté la référence, mais c'est dans l'Ancien Testament,
contre Balaam, si je ne me trompe pas.
Dieu utilise un âne pour s'adresser en langage humain à cet homme.
Eh bien, c'est le même élément de la création,
mais cette fois-ci utilisé de manière miraculeuse.
parce que ça va au-delà ou à travers les lois naturelles de l'âne
qui n'est pas de parler à un être humain.
Dans le premier cas, Jésus, quand il dit d'avance où va se trouver cet âne,
il manifeste clairement son omniscience, l'omniscience de sa nature divine.
Et Dieu est intervenu dans la création,
en utilisant les jours d'avant, les semaines, voire plus,
toute une série d'intermédiaires et de successions de causes
pour que l'âne se trouve à ce jour-là, à cette heure-là, à cet endroit,
tel que Jésus l'avait annoncé.
Mais tout s'est passé selon les lois naturelles de la création.
Il n'y a pas eu de miracle, mais il y a eu une gouvernance de Dieu,
une intervention providentielle de Dieu.
Et dans le deuxième cas de l'âne qui parle,
c'est donc le même élément qui est utilisé par Dieu,
mais cette fois-ci, Dieu intervient directement et contre,
malgré les lois naturelles, puisque l'âne s'adresse à Balaam dans un langage humain,
ce qui, à ma connaissance, n'est pas quelque chose qu'un âne fait généralement.
Donc voici, pour répondre à la question de notre frère,
quelques rappels de définition, ce seront des rappels en tout cas pour ceux qui étaient là
dans les enseignements de David, qui viennent volontairement de sources réformées,
mais qui sont variées pour vous montrer qu'il y a une unité des théologiens
sur ce sujet de la providence.
Donc par exemple, le catéchisme de Heidelberg à la question 27 dit
« La providence de Dieu, c'est la puissance toute puissante et présente de Dieu
par laquelle il maintient le ciel et la terre avec toutes les créatures. »
Turtin dit dans un de ses ouvrages
Je ne le cite pas parce que le nom est très long.
« La providence est l'acte externe et temporel de Dieu
selon lequel il conserve et gouverne toute chose créée. »
Et pour finir avec notre confession de foi,
pour relire ce qu'on a déjà lu les dernières semaines,
dans sa providence, Dieu normalement se sert de moyen.
Il est cependant libre d'agir sans ses moyens,
par-dessus ses moyens ou contre eux si tel est son plaisir.
C'est-à-dire que, pour traduire un peu,
de manière commune, Dieu intervient dans sa création par la providence,
mais il est libre, comme on l'a vu, d'agir miraculeusement,
c'est-à-dire par-dessus, contre ou sans ses moyens naturels
qu'il a mis en place dans sa création.
Et pour définir donc le miracle,
Bénédicte Piqueté dit la chose suivante
« Le miracle est un effet extraordinaire qui dépasse les forces de la nature
et qui a pour but de confirmer la parole de Dieu. »
Je ne vais pas trop m'étendre sur cet aspect de révélation des miracles,
mais c'est quand même à noter.
Et Louis Bercoff dit
« Les miracles sont des œuvres puissantes de Dieu
qui ne peuvent être expliquées par les lois naturelles
et qui sont destinées à manifester sa puissance et sa présence. »
Donc, pour répondre à la première des questions que j'ai réunies,
oui, il faut faire la distinction.
Je ne dirais pas la différence,
je ne m'étale pas sur la différence entre ces deux termes,
mais je dirais oui, il faut faire la distinction
entre miracle et providence
parce que ça permet tout simplement de bien comprendre
et de bien apprécier les deux grandes manières
que Dieu a d'intervenir dans sa création.
Il y avait donc dans les questions
« Qu'est-ce que ça change pour nous ? »
Il y avait cette question aussi,
là j'ai noté quel rôle joue la présence de Dieu dans notre quotidien.
Il y avait une autre question qui était plus formulée en disant
« Qu'est-ce que ça change pour nous de faire cette distinction,
de la comprendre ? »
Eh bien, je dirais que ça nous permet déjà
d'avoir une meilleure compréhension de Dieu,
de ses œuvres,
donc une meilleure théologie,
et ce n'est pas une mauvaise chose,
une meilleure compréhension des doctrines bibliques.
Voilà, quand on articule bien les choses,
c'est toujours bénéfique pour nous, spirituellement.
Et ça va nous permettre aussi, comme je le disais,
non seulement de mieux comprendre,
c'est la première étape,
mais aussi de mieux apprécier
les différentes manières que Dieu a d'intervenir dans nos vies.
Et je dirais notamment par sa providence.
Pourquoi c'est important ?
Eh bien, ça nous permet de ne pas dépendre de révélations
ou d'interventions miraculeuses de Dieu pour avancer dans notre vie,
que ce soit pour les décisions de notre vie si bas ou dans notre foi.
Il y a des chrétiens qui n'avancent pas,
sont immobiles dans leur foi,
tant qu'ils ne considèrent pas qu'ils ont reçu une révélation spéciale
ou une intervention évidente, miraculeuse de Dieu dans leur vie.
Bien comprendre ce qu'est la providence
permet de ne pas dépendre de ce genre d'interventions miraculeuses.
Ça permet aussi de ne pas négliger,
voire pour certains chrétiens ou d'autres convictions religieuses,
de refuser la grâce commune de Dieu,
qui est l'expression de sa bonté envers toute la race humaine
à travers sa providence.
Par exemple, refuser certains soins,
certains traitements,
s'attendre exclusivement à une guérison miraculeuse de Dieu
sans faire usage des éléments de cette grâce commune
qu'il a mis en place, des intermédiaires comme les médecins
ou la médecine, les médicaments, etc.
Il y a des chrétiens ou il y a d'autres courants religieux
qui sont opposés à ça.
Et s'ils sont malades ou qu'ils ont des proches malades, par exemple,
vont attendre une guérison directe et miraculeuse de Dieu
et vont refuser de faire usage des moyens
que Dieu a permis qu'ils soient dans ce monde pour les guérir.
Et je dirais enfin que cela va permettre aux chrétiens
à la fois de ne pas voir des miracles partout,
comme si dès que Dieu gouverne les choses en sa faveur,
c'est un miracle,
mais aussi de ne voir Dieu nulle part,
comme si l'absence de miracle,
en l'absence de miracle,
Dieu n'avait rien accompli.
Donc, ça permet de rééquilibrer ces deux choses.
Dieu agit et intervient souvent et communément
par sa providence
et parfois dans des contextes bien précis
où cela est pertinent et selon sa volonté,
par des miracles.
Et pour terminer plus rapidement
avec la troisième question ou sous-question,
la providence s'applique-t-elle aussi aux non-croyants ?
Je pense avoir déjà répondu
ou donné des éléments de réponse
en parlant de la grâce commune.
Donc, la réponse est oui.
Tout simplement parce que rien ni personne
n'échappe à la providence de Dieu
qui est la gouvernance de Dieu,
de sa création.
Aucune créature,
aucun élément de la création
n'échappe à cela
et c'est ce qu'exprime très simplement
Herman Bavink,
donc une autre référence réformée.
Il n'y a pas d'atome dans l'univers
qui soit en dehors du contrôle de Dieu.
Pas un seul atome de la création de Dieu
n'échappe à sa providence,
à sa gouvernance.
Donc, comme nous l'avons vu
avec notre cher pasteur David
dans les leçons sur ce sujet de la providence,
tout homme est soumis à la providence
et tout homme bénéficie de la providence.
C'est plus que les chrétiens
bénéficient de moyens de grâce supplémentaires,
de soins et de grâce supplémentaires
de la part de Dieu,
d'un soin particulier,
d'un amour
ou de manifestation d'amour particulière.
Les chrétiens bénéficient de cela
en plus du reste
que tout homme expérimente
par la providence de Dieu.
Donc voilà pour répondre
à ces différentes questions regroupées.
Donc si ma réponse a apporté
plus de questions que de réponses,
n'hésitez pas à le dire
et à poser vos questions
et les autres,
enfin les anciens,
à répondre
ou à compléter ma réponse.
T'as eu la réponse à ta question mon frère ?
Ok super.
C'est vrai que c'était la base.
Merci.
Pour reprendre le contexte
pour la question de Jérémie,
en fait, en ce moment,
pour ceux qui nous rejoignent
depuis plus récemment,
on est en train d'étudier
la confession de foi
baptiste de Londres
de 1689.
On a traversé
plusieurs chapitres,
notamment la création
et le décret.
Ensuite,
vient le chapitre 5
qu'on a vu là depuis
quelques semaines,
pas plusieurs mois d'ailleurs.
le chapitre 5
de la providence de Dieu.
Donc,
effectivement,
c'est l'action de Dieu
par laquelle il gouverne,
il maintient,
il soutient toute chose,
toute sa création
dans le but
de mener son décret.
Donc,
c'est aussi pour ça que,
notamment,
dans la confession de foi,
il y a eu le choix
de mettre,
comme David nous l'expliquait,
la création
et le décret
avant l'étude
de la providence de Dieu
pour qu'on comprenne
à la fois la fin
de toute chose
que Dieu a décrété,
mais aussi le moyen
par lequel le Seigneur
va soutenir absolument
toute chose dans l'univers
pour mettre un terme
au décret
et comment il va maintenir
toute la création.
C'est aussi pour ça
qu'on a vu le chapitre
de la création
en amont,
dans la confession de foi.
Vas-y,
pose sa question
puis je la redirai
dans le micro
pour l'enregistrement.
Je voulais demander
est-ce qu'on pourrait avoir
les références
des citations
que tu as dites
tout à l'heure ?
Oui, sans problème.
D'accord.
Les références,
je peux les envoyer
sans souci.
D'accord.
Ah, les références précises,
oui, oui,
elles sont notées.
Je n'ai pas dit
pas l'oral
parce que parfois
c'est compliqué,
mais...
Oui, ça peut
s'alardir encore plus
le...
Oui,
c'est pas toujours clair
à l'oral
de toute façon.
Mais je ne les ai pas écrites,
je peux les donner
sans problème.
Et je voulais
par rapport
à l'amour
supplémentaire
par rapport
à ce commune.
En tant que chrétien,
souvent,
on vit des épreuves
ou des situations
qui peuvent paraître
beaucoup plus lourdes
que les gens
qui ne sont pas chrétiens.
Et je ne sais pas
comment l'exprimer,
mais des fois,
on a la sensation
même,
on a un pardo supplémentaire.
Je ne saurais pas
comment exprimer
la question,
mais je ne sais pas
si tu vois
ou je veux en dire.
Si, si, je vois.
C'est vrai que
Dieu nous aime,
mais des fois,
on se sent bien misérable
et bien...
bien payant la grâce
de Jésus,
on a l'impression
d'avoir
un peu moins cette grâce
que nous sommes
quelque part.
C'est assez contradictoire,
contradictoire,
contradictoire.
dans certaines situations.
Il y a beaucoup
d'épreuves,
beaucoup de luttes
et je ne sais pas
comment mieux définir
la chose
et comment mieux
peut-être se comporter
ou réagir
à ce genre de situation.
Peut-être qu'il y a
un peu plus d'épreuve
et que je ne sais pas
de la chose.
Donc, je me permets
de garder ta question réserve
parce qu'elle va être
traitée un peu plus loin.
Pour ma part,
en tout cas,
si les autres veulent
répondre tout de suite,
n'hésitez pas.
Mais moi,
on va pas mal
s'arrêter sur ce point-là.
Comment considérer
la souffrance
et notamment
dans la vie chrétienne,
en tant que chrétien,
face à cette doctrine
de la providence ?
Je pense qu'on peut
la prêter ensemble
en arrivant là.
Ok, pas de soucis.
S'il y aurait d'autres questions
avant qu'on avance ?
Oui ?
La providence.
La grâce commune ?
La grâce commune,
c'est que la providence de Dieu
s'applique à tout le monde.
En fait,
la question,
est-ce que la grâce commune,
c'est le fait
que la providence de Dieu
s'applique à tout le monde ?
Je dirais que la grâce commune,
c'est un aspect
de la providence de Dieu.
On pourrait dire
une sous-catégorie
de la providence de Dieu.
La providence de Dieu,
c'est un terme général
qui dit simplement
que Dieu a tout créé,
certes,
mais ensuite,
il n'est pas parti
en vacances
et il gouverne,
il entretient,
il soutient,
il gouverne toute sa création,
chaque jour,
à chaque instant.
Et s'il arrêtait de le faire,
tout s'écroulerait.
Donc,
c'est ça la doctrine
de la providence.
On pourrait simplifier
en disant que c'est la gouvernance
de Dieu sur sa création.
Et donc,
dans cette gouvernance,
Dieu peut faire
toutes sortes de choses.
il peut,
si on se concentre
sur les êtres humains,
et sans parler de chrétiens,
forcément,
il peut décider
de,
dès cette vie,
juger des mauvaises actions
des hommes.
ce n'est pas la providence,
même si on a raison
de mettre l'emphase
sur l'aspect bénéfique,
parce que c'est d'abord
le fait que Dieu soutienne
toute chose,
pourvoie,
dirige,
majoritairement pour le bien,
toute sa création
pour le bien de ses créatures.
Mais il y a aussi
des aspects plus,
on pourrait dire,
dans un sens,
ce n'est pas vraiment le cas,
mais négatives.
Dieu peut,
par exemple,
il permet que,
c'est lui qui décide
quand un homme va naître,
mais aussi mourir,
tout un tas de choses
plutôt négatives,
mais aussi énormément
de choses positives.
Et donc ça,
c'est ce qu'on regroupe
sous le terme
de grâce commune.
C'est tout simplement
la bonté de Dieu
qui s'adresse,
qui s'exprime
et s'applique
à toutes ses créatures,
et en particulier,
quand on parle
de grâce commune
à toute l'humanité.
Donc évidemment,
à distinguer
de la grâce
ou des grâces particulières
que Dieu réserve
pour ses enfants,
en Christ.
Il y a très souvent
dans la théologie chrétienne
cette distinction
entre révélation générale
et particulière,
grâce commune
et grâce particulière.
Voilà.
Donc c'est tout simplement
la bonté de Dieu
qui s'exprime
envers toute l'humanité,
la grâce commune.
Et ensuite,
tu peux...
Il y a plein de facettes
à cette grâce commune.
Le fait qu'il y ait
de la nourriture,
le fait que Dieu
ait permis,
malgré les effets
négatifs du péché
sur l'homme,
que l'homme développe
la médecine,
des sciences,
des choses qui permettent
de continuer à vivre
dans ce monde
et d'améliorer
sa condition de vie même.
Voilà.
tout...
C'est un très grand sujet.
La notion de grâce commune,
elle permet de répondre
à quelque chose
qui peut nous paraître illogique,
c'est-à-dire comment,
dans un monde corrompu,
rebelle,
qui est condamné
à la malédiction,
qui est maudit
et qui est condamné
à sa perdition,
comment on peut toujours
voir de bonnes choses
et des choses
qui sont profitables,
des choses qui sont appréciables.
Si l'humanité
est ennemie de Dieu,
si l'humanité
a corrompu le monde,
comment ça se fait
qu'on puisse encore
profiter de bonnes choses ?
Donc, il y a des réponses
qu'on peut trouver
pour les racheter,
qui sont sous le soin particulier
de l'affection de Dieu.
Mais il y a des choses
qui peuvent nous paraître
si on a une bonne compréhension
de la sainteté de Dieu
et si on a une bonne compréhension
du péché.
Il y a quelque chose
qui peut nous paraître
assez illogique
de comprendre
comment ce monde
continue de tourner.
Le soleil se lève
encore chaque matin,
les nuages arrivent
et font pleuvoir
même sur les pires criminels
de ce monde
qui peuvent manger,
qui peuvent s'enrichir,
qui sont pour certains
en bonne santé.
Et donc, effectivement,
c'est pour ça
qu'il y a aussi
ce mot grâce
dans la définition
de grâce commune.
C'est la manifestation
de la bonté
imméritée
de Dieu
envers une humanité
corrompue.
Donc, effectivement,
le mot providence,
la providence de Dieu,
c'est une action
plus générale de Dieu
sur toute sa création.
C'est une définition
un peu plus générale.
Donc, tout,
que ce soit la providence
de Dieu
ou la grâce commune,
tout converge
pour la gloire de Dieu.
C'est la fin de toute chose.
Mais disons que
quand on parle
de la grâce commune,
effectivement,
comme Adinat,
c'est davantage
une manifestation
de la bonté
directement envers
l'humanité,
même l'humanité déchue
et corrompue
et rebelle contre lui.
Il fait pleuvoir
sur le juste
et sur l'injuste.
Ça, c'est la grâce commune.
Comment on peut
se réjouir
en dansant,
en écoutant même
de la musique
qui aiguait nos âmes,
même de la musique
faite par des personnes
qui ne sont pas converties.
Ça fait, bon,
après,
c'est très vaste
comme Adinat,
on peut sous-diviser,
mais tout ça,
ça fait partie
de la grâce commune.
Oui ?
Est-ce que les actions
de l'Église,
comme par exemple,
des réponses
à l'évangélisation
ou à recevoir,
par exemple,
quelqu'un de particulier
pour arriver
ou pour créer l'Église,
est-ce que ça fait partie
de la providence de Dieu
ou c'est encore
dans une autre catégorie ?
Excuse-moi,
est-ce que tu peux
juste préciser
ce que tu entends ?
Enfin, l'exemple
que tu as donné,
je ne suis pas sûr
de bien le comprendre.
Quand on reçoit
quelqu'un en particulier,
tu disais ?
Oui, est-ce que,
par exemple,
si une Église
se crée à un endroit
où il n'y avait pas
la parole de Dieu,
par exemple,
ou au contraire,
la parole
était trichée
d'une bonne manière,
est-ce que c'est la grâce ?
Par exemple,
est-ce que l'Église
Bonne Nouvelle,
c'est la providence
ou c'est encore
dans une autre catégorie ?
Regroupée sous la providence de Dieu.
Tout ce qui se passe
dans la création
est le fruit
de la providence de Dieu.
Comme je l'ai dit,
c'est la gouvernance
de Dieu de sa création.
Il n'y a absolument
rien qui se fait.
Comme on l'a vu
dans cette citation,
il n'y a pas un atome
qui bouge,
qui échappe
à la gouvernance de Dieu,
à la providence de Dieu.
Donc après,
oui,
un peu comme la grâce commune,
on peut faire
des sous-catégories
et on le fait en théologie
pour bien comprendre,
distinguer les choses.
Mais en tout cas,
si la question,
c'est est-ce que ça fait partie
ou est-ce que c'est la providence ?
Oui,
car tout est la providence.
Rien n'arrive par hasard
et rien ne se fait
sans ou en dehors
la providence de Dieu.
Je pense qu'on va avancer
sur le groupe,
le deuxième groupe
de questions
qui va nous permettre
à la fois d'aborder
toujours ce sujet
de la providence,
mais en l'appliquant
au champ
un thème
qui revient souvent
dans les églises
qui intéresse
les membres
et c'est normal
et qui est le mariage
ou en tout cas
la recherche
d'un conjoint,
le choix d'un conjoint.
Donc,
les questions
que je vais aborder
sont les suivantes.
En tant que chrétien,
faut-il croire au destin ?
Donc, ça aussi,
c'est une bonne occasion
de clarifier
certaines définitions
qui ont vraiment
leur importance.
Car,
donc la deuxième question
est liée à celle-ci,
car il est souvent évoqué
qu'il faut trouver
la femme de sa destinée
ou l'homme de sa destinée.
Donc,
que penser
de telle déclaration ?
Et comment être convaincu
que ce n'est pas
la providence de Dieu
ou au contraire
que c'est sa providence
qui permet
un rapprochement
entre un homme
et une femme ?
Je vais dire
entre un chrétien
et une chrétienne
pour simplifier un peu
et raccourcir la réponse.
Mais tout d'abord,
en tant que chrétien,
faut-il croire au destin ?
Alors,
le destin,
on pourrait croire
que c'est la même chose
que la souveraineté divine
ou le décret divin.
Mais c'est une grosse erreur
de croire ça.
Une grosse erreur
que beaucoup d'entre nous,
malheureusement,
ont fait ou font encore.
Même dans les églises.
Et je pense aussi
que c'est cette confusion
qui est à l'origine
du rejet des doctrines,
de la souveraineté divine,
du décret divin,
de la prédestination,
de l'élection.
La confusion
qui peut exister
chez certaines personnes
entre la souveraineté divine
et le destin
ou même le fatalisme.
Donc,
qu'est-ce que c'est le destin ?
Il faut déjà savoir
d'où ça vient cette idée
et bien le définir.
Ça vient,
bon,
je vous passe le terme en latin,
il n'est pas très important,
mais le sens du mot latin
veut dire fixé.
Donc,
c'est quelque chose
qui est figé,
qui ne bouge pas
dans son étymologie.
Et ça désigne,
notamment dans la culture générale
qu'on a aujourd'hui
mais qui est héritée
de la philosophie grecque
en ce qui concerne ce terme,
ça désigne une force
qui est,
et là,
c'est important de noter
les qualificatifs,
impersonnelle,
inévitable
et fatal.
Ça,
c'est plus ou moins
des synonymes,
inévitable et fatal,
qui déterminent d'avance
le cours
de tous les événements
du monde.
Dans la mythologie grecque,
et ça,
c'est un point vraiment important
pour faire la,
pour l'aborder face
à la doctrine
de la souveraineté divine
ou de la providence,
dans la mythologie grecque,
le destin était personnifié
par les moires,
donc,
bon,
voilà,
il était personnifié,
ça,
ce n'est pas le point important,
des personnes
qui filaient,
qui mesuraient
et coupaient
le fil de la vie
de chacun,
y compris des dieux.
Ça,
c'est le point important
à noter.
Donc,
cette vision
qui est une vision fataliste,
une vision impersonnelle,
inévitable
et souvent cruelle,
qui échappe même,
donc,
qui échappe à la volonté humaine,
bien sûr,
mais même
à la volonté divine.
Donc,
dans le contexte des grecs,
c'était les dieux,
mais,
bon,
notre dieu
rentre dans cette définition
parmi les autres dieux.
selon la définition du destin,
ça voudrait dire
que c'est une force
qui est supérieure même
à Dieu,
à laquelle Dieu lui-même
est soumis
et ne peut échapper.
Donc,
vous aurez déjà remarqué,
je pense,
à travers cette définition,
les problèmes
de cette notion de destin
quand on la met face
à la doctrine biblique
du décret divin.
Il n'y a pas de force
impersonnelle,
il n'y a pas de force
inévitable et cruelle
qui s'impose
et qui échappe
à la volonté humaine.
Et encore moins
à la volonté de Dieu.
Il faut bien comprendre
que le destin,
c'est l'idée
d'une force
indépendante,
supérieure à tout,
qui dirige
le cours de l'histoire
et contre laquelle
personne ne peut rien,
pas même Dieu.
La Bible enseigne au contraire
que ce n'est pas
une force impersonnelle,
mais que c'est Dieu
et sa volonté,
une volonté
qui est celle de Dieu
donc parfaitement sage,
bonne,
un Dieu personnel
qui gouverne
et qui dirige
le cours de l'histoire.
Le décret de Dieu
est saint,
il est sage,
il est libre,
il est plein d'amour,
en particulier
d'amour pour ses enfants
et comme on l'a vu
même envers toute l'humanité
par la grâce commune.
Et donc,
contrairement au destin,
la providence de Dieu,
c'est l'action constante
de Dieu
qui soutient,
dirige et gouverne
toutes ses créatures.
Il n'y a rien
au-dessus de ça.
Il n'y a pas
de force indépendante
et encore moins supérieure
à Dieu et sa volonté.
Et c'est notamment vrai
puisque je veux mentionner
la prédestination,
l'élection
qui sont des,
on parlait de sous-catégories,
des sous-catégories
de la providence de Dieu
en ce qui concerne
le salut de l'homme.
Ce n'est rien de plus que ça.
Ce sont des termes
qui définissent plus précisément
comment la providence de Dieu
intervient dans la vie
d'une personne
pour la sauver.
Ce n'est pas une force impersonnelle,
c'est Dieu lui-même
qui prédestine certains
à la vie éternelle,
et qui intervient personnellement
dans leur vie
de manière personnelle,
aimante,
sainte,
pour les sauver.
Ce n'est pas une fatalité aveugle,
un personnel qui fait ça.
Et pour citer
quelques versets bibliques,
en lui,
nous sommes,
donc en Christ,
nous sommes aussi devenus héritiers,
ayant été prédestinés,
suivant le destin,
non,
la résolution de celui
qui opère toute chose
d'après le conseil
de sa volonté,
c'est-à-dire Dieu.
Nous savons du reste,
une autre citation,
Romain 8,
verset 28,
nous savons du reste
que toute chose concourt
au bien de ceux qui aiment Dieu,
de ceux qui sont appelés
selon son dessein.
Donc voilà,
pour résumer sur ce point
du destin,
le destin en tant que force aveugle,
impersonnelle,
supérieur à Dieu,
n'a aucune place
dans la théologie chrétienne,
la théologie réformée.
la Bible enseigne plutôt
la souveraineté bienveillante
et personnelle de Dieu
qui gouverne l'univers
avec sagesse,
avec amour,
qui accomplit son plan parfait
dans le temps
et dans l'éternité.
Je m'arrête là
si jamais il y a besoin
de clarification
ou d'autres questions
avant d'aborder
l'application
de ce sujet-là,
comme on l'a dit
à la recherche du conjoint.
Je suis sûr qu'il n'y aura pas
de questions
pour qu'on passe vite
à ce sujet.
OK, pas de souci.
Moi, j'ai une question.
Parfois, j'ai tenu
à quelques gens
dire des phrases
comme chercher les buts
ou quand on n'est pas les buts,
mais ce que Dieu a pour toi.
en réserve pour toi.
Voilà,
chercher la raison
de laquelle ça crée
ou tout comme ça,
mais tout l'orienter
vers, je ne sais pas,
vers une profession
ou vers un service.
Comment chercher ton appel ?
Comment on peut
aborder ces sujets
et donner une réponse ?
Je ne sais pas,
parfois,
ce n'est pas peut-être
intéressant,
mais en fait,
on nous donne
tous les détails
de la biologie et tout ça,
mais d'une façon
plus claire
et parfois directe.
Justement,
le sujet du mariage
va nous permettre
d'aborder exactement ça.
Voilà,
parce qu'en fait,
même parfois aussi
dans le sens
où il faut chercher
l'ordre
que Dieu a destiné
pour que Dieu a...
C'est exactement
ce dont on va parler
juste après.
Donc,
est-ce qu'on va dire là
sur le mariage
et répondre à ta question
est vrai pour les autres sujets ?
Enfin,
tu verras que ça s'applique
aux autres sujets
comme un travail
ou les autres choix
de la vie.
Bon,
on avance alors.
Donc,
elle a dit
qu'elle voulait
la poser après.
Donc,
je relis
la sous-question
qui est souvent évoquée
qu'il faut trouver
la femme de sa destinée
ou l'homme de sa destinée,
la personne
qui est réservée pour nous
et donc,
que penser
de telle déclaration ?
C'est une bonne question
et ça va nous permettre
d'aborder un sujet
qui est important,
de définir un autre terme
qui est généralement
pas utilisé en tant que tel
mais qui est une notion
qui est en arrière-plan
dans la pensée de beaucoup
et qui génère
ce genre de questions
ou la façon
dont on y répond aussi.
Donc,
moi,
ce n'est pas la première fois
que j'entends cette question.
Comment savoir
si c'est la personne
que Dieu a choisi pour moi,
que Dieu en réserve pour moi,
si c'est la personne
avec qui je dois me marier ?
Et donc,
je le mentionnais
juste à l'instant,
je ne dis pas,
je ne pense pas
que c'est toujours le cas
mais que souvent,
la façon dont est formulée
cette question
ou ce qu'il y a
en arrière-plan
dans la question,
s'est influencée
par une autre notion païenne.
On a vu la notion païenne
du destin.
Eh bien là,
il y a une autre notion païenne
qui nous vient aussi
des Grecs,
de Platon plus précisément
et qui est le mythe
de l'âme sœur.
Est-ce que vous avez déjà
entendu ce terme ?
Il faut trouver l'âme sœur.
Est-ce que vous…
Oui,
je vais y répondre,
mais c'est des expressions
qu'on entend
dans notre culture
comme ça,
qui sont des expressions
dont on ne connaît souvent
pas l'origine
et encore moins le sens.
mais le sens est très important.
Vous allez le voir.
Donc,
très rapidement
pour le contexte,
ce mythe de l'âme sœur,
donc j'ai dit,
ça vient de Platon,
plus précisément
d'une œuvre
qui s'appelle
Le Banquet,
qui est un dialogue
philosophique sur l'amour,
un dialogue philosophique
fictif
que Platon a rédigé
où les personnages
de ce banquet
qui sont réunis
dialoguent
sur l'amour,
notamment Aristophane
qui est un des convives.
Notez
que il y a beaucoup…
la plupart des convives
sont homosexuels,
c'était institutionnalisé
à cette époque
dans la société grecque,
donc il y a beaucoup
d'apologies,
même de l'homosexualité
et au milieu de tout ça,
il y a ce mythe
de l'âme sœur
qui est un mythe
sur l'origine de l'amour,
ni plus ni moins,
que Platon développe.
Et donc,
selon ce mythe
de l'âme sœur
sur l'origine de l'amour,
ça parle aussi
en même temps
de l'origine
des êtres humains.
Et donc,
voici ce que Platon suppose
ou invente,
je ne sais pas comment dire.
Les êtres humains
étaient à l'origine
des créatures sphériques
à quatre bras,
quatre jambes,
deux visages,
etc.
Je ne sais même pas
ce que c'est,
etc.
Mais beaucoup de choses
en tout cas
dans ces corps
en double et en quadruple.
Ils étaient masculins,
féminins ou androgynes
et puissants.
Peut-être des demi-dieux,
je ne sais pas.
Et donc,
les dieux,
jaloux et inquiets
de ces créatures puissantes,
les ont coupés en deux
pour diminuer une moitié
leur force,
j'imagine.
Et donc,
depuis ce jour-là,
depuis que les dieux
ont coupé
ces êtres humains en deux,
chaque moitié
cherche désespérément
sa moitié perdue
pour retrouver sa plénitude,
la plénitude de son être.
Voici ce que dit Platon.
Chacun de nous est donc
la moitié d'un être humain
entier coupé en deux
comme une sole,
c'est-à-dire comme un poisson
qu'on coupe en deux
pour faire défiler.
Chacun cherche toujours
sa moitié.
J'espère que vous êtes
heureux d'apprendre
qu'à la base,
vous aviez quatre jambes,
deux visages,
que c'est pour ça
qu'aujourd'hui,
vous n'en avez plus que deux
et un.
C'est parce que vous êtes
coupés en deux
et qu'il faut retrouver
votre moitié,
sinon vous n'êtes que
la moitié d'un être humain.
Voilà.
Les Grecs nous ont apporté
beaucoup de choses
très positives
mais aussi des moins positives.
Donc, autant vous dire
qu'il n'y a pas grand-chose
de moins biblique
que cette idée de l'âme sœur,
que ce mythe de l'âme sœur.
Bien sûr,
lorsque les chrétiens
posent cette question
est-ce que c'est la personne,
ils n'ont pas cette définition
en tête,
ils n'ont pas ce mythe
en tête, heureusement.
Enfin, je l'espère
pour la plupart.
Mais c'est toujours important
comme je disais de savoir
d'où viennent les termes,
les notions,
les mots qu'on entend
et qui circulent.
Voilà.
Et qu'on utilise parfois aussi.
Ou qu'on utilise consciemment
ou inconsciemment.
Donc, revenons maintenant
à cette question
comment être convaincu
que c'est la providence de Dieu
qui permet un rapprochement
avec un homme
ou avec une femme.
Comment savoir
si c'est cette personne
avec qui je dois me marier ?
Et donc, comme souvent,
lorsqu'on aborde la relation
entre la volonté
et la responsabilité humaine
et la souveraineté de Dieu,
il faut bien distinguer
les deux niveaux suivants.
C'est très important.
Il y a d'abord Dieu
qui est hors du temps
pour qu'il n'y a ni passé,
ni présent,
ni futur.
Tous les éléments
de l'histoire
de sa création
sont à chaque instant
devant ses yeux.
Le déroulement de l'histoire
qu'il a lui-même écrit.
Et donc,
c'est vrai que tout ce qui arrive,
c'est la volonté de Dieu
que rien ne peut échapper
à son décret éternel,
à sa providence.
On l'a vu.
Ça,
c'est le niveau de Dieu
hors du temps.
Toute l'histoire face à lui,
ni passé,
ni présent,
ni futur.
Après,
il y a notre niveau à nous.
Hommes déjà,
créatures de Dieu,
coincées ou prises dans le temps.
C'est comme ça
que Dieu nous a créés.
Et ce n'est pas
notre responsabilité
de percer à jour
le décret divin.
Ce n'est pas notre responsabilité
d'essayer,
par je ne sais quel moyen,
d'atteindre ce niveau de Dieu
pour contempler comme lui
ses décrets divins,
ses décrets éternels.
Nous ne le pouvons pas
et si nous ne le pouvons pas,
c'est que c'est bien ainsi.
Et ce n'est pas…
Dieu ne nous appelle pas
à faire ça.
Tout ce que nous pouvons faire
par rapport au décret éternel de Dieu,
c'est regarder en arrière
et constater que voici,
c'était bien la volonté décrétive de Dieu.
Notez ce terme,
il est très important.
Il y a deux termes
qui vont être très importants
pour cette réponse.
La volonté d'abord décrétive de Dieu.
C'est tout ce qui se passe,
c'est la volonté décrétive de Dieu.
Dieu l'a décrétée,
il l'a voulue ainsi,
c'est sa volonté décrétive.
Et ce que Dieu nous a révélé par contre,
donc il ne nous a pas révélé,
je crois, personne,
sa volonté décrétive.
Par contre, il nous a révélé
sa volonté prescriptive,
deuxième terme qu'il faut noter.
Il l'a fait de différentes manières.
Par sa loi naturelle,
à travers la révélation générale de la création.
Il l'a fait bien plus précisément encore,
évidemment,
par sa loi morale,
à travers la révélation spéciale de sa parole,
qui vient confirmer et préciser
la révélation générale.
et ça, c'est donc accessible à nous tous,
par sa grâce.
Et Dieu nous demande d'être responsables
en dirigeant nos vies,
non pas selon sa volonté décrétive,
mais selon sa volonté prescriptive,
qui nous a révélés
et qui est basée donc sur cette révélation générale
et spéciale de Dieu envers les hommes.
Et donc,
l'erreur
que nous faisons,
à mon avis,
trop souvent,
lorsqu'on se pose ce genre de questions,
comment savoir si c'est la personne ?
Comment savoir si c'est ce métier que je dois faire ?
Comment, voilà,
mais concentrons-nous sur la question.
Comment savoir si c'est la personne ?
Ce que nous cherchons à faire en réalité,
c'est à nous baser sur la volonté décrétive de Dieu.
Et non,
ou en tout cas pas seulement,
sur sa volonté prescriptive.
Et selon ce que je viens de définir,
c'est peine perdue.
John Piper l'a dit une fois,
tout ce que nous sommes en mesure de faire
lorsqu'on se demande,
si jamais ça nous arrive,
pour ceux qui sont déjà mariés,
est-ce que c'était la volonté de Dieu
que j'épouse cette personne ?
Est-ce que je me suis vraiment marié
avec la bonne personne ?
Tout ce qu'on peut faire,
dit John Piper,
c'est regarder le nom qui est écrit
sur l'acte de mariage de la mairie
et de constater
comme je le disais tout à l'heure,
rétroactivement.
Oui, en effet,
c'était la volonté décrétive de Dieu.
Il l'a voulu ainsi.
Mais ce n'est pas quelque chose
qu'on peut savoir à l'avance.
On peut juste le constater après.
Et donc maintenant,
si on se pose cette question
avant de se marier,
puisque c'est le cas ici,
eh bien, il est vain de chercher
à savoir si c'est la volonté décrétive de Dieu
que j'épouse cette personne.
Car je l'ai dit,
on ne peut pas découvrir ça à l'avance.
Et de toute façon,
la volonté décrétive de Dieu
s'appliquera de toute manière.
Ça ne sert à rien
d'essayer de la découvrir.
Elle s'appliquera de toute façon.
Donc, nous la ferons forcément.
Personne ne peut enfreindre
cette volonté-là.
Par contre,
on peut enfreindre
la volonté prescriptive de Dieu.
Celle-ci,
on peut y désobéir.
On peut la transgresser,
malheureusement,
à cause du péché.
Donc, par exemple,
si un homme regarde
son acte de mariage
et il voit le nom
d'une femme non-chrétienne,
il peut dire
c'est la volonté décrétive de Dieu
que j'ai épousé cette personne.
Par contre,
ce n'était pas
la volonté prescriptive de Dieu
qui nous interdit
très clairement
dans sa parole
de nous unir
à un non-croyant.
On ne peut donc jamais
enfreindre la volonté décrétive
mais on peut enfreindre
la volonté prescriptive.
Ce que nous devons faire
face à cette question
très importante
pour notre vie ici-bas,
c'est sûr,
c'est donc
pas chercher
à connaître
la volonté décrétive
mais à connaître
le mieux possible
la volonté prescriptive de Dieu
pour le mariage
qui nous a révélé
dans sa création
et surtout dans sa parole
et qui est vrai,
qui s'applique
à chaque chrétien
et à chaque chrétienne.
Et ce qui est intéressant
de relever,
c'est que les principes
bibliques qui doivent
nous permettre
de définir
si telle sœur
ou tel frère
peut être notre conjoint
selon la volonté de Dieu
sont à la fois
dans sa parole
objectif,
simple
et finalement
pas très nombreux.
Donc ça veut dire
que tous les frères en Christ,
pour revenir vraiment
dans la pratique,
tous les frères en Christ
qui correspondent
aux critères bibliques
d'un mari chrétien
et toutes les sœurs en Christ
qui correspondent
aux critères bibliques
d'une épouse chrétienne
sont pour vous
qui cherchez un conjoint,
des candidats légitimes
au mariage.
Nous ne devons pas
tomber dans le piège
de retrouver l'âme sœur
comme Platon le propose.
Il n'y a pas une femme
compatible avec vous
les frères,
il n'y a pas un homme
compatible avec vous
les sœurs.
Et c'est aussi ça d'ailleurs
pour faire une parenthèse
qui rend le remariage possible.
S'il n'y avait
qu'une seule personne
compatible,
une fois qu'on l'a trouvée
qu'on s'est marié avec,
si jamais il advenait
qu'on doive se remarier,
ce qui est autorisé
dans certains cas
bibliquement,
ce ne serait pas possible.
Donc,
tant que nous respectons
la volonté prescriptive
de Dieu qui est
que nous ne nous mettions pas
sous un joug étranger
en nous mariant
avec un non-croyant,
eh bien,
j'ai envie de dire
tout est envisageable.
Tous les autres paramètres
que vous allez prendre en compte
peuvent plus ou moins
faciliter le mariage,
aspects physiques,
cultures,
communes ou différentes,
intérêts communs,
richesses,
maladies, etc.
Il y a tout un tas
de paramètres
qui peuvent avoir
leur importance
mais qui ne seront pas
des paramètres
de légitimité
pour le mariage.
Donc,
comment être convaincu
que c'est la providence
de Dieu
qui permet un rapprochement
avec un homme
ou une femme
ou comment savoir
si c'est avec cette personne
que je dois me marier ?
Ma réponse finale
sera assez courte,
on n'aura que deux points,
en faisant tous nos efforts
pour nous assurer
de la foi authentique
de cette personne.
Donc là,
ça implique beaucoup de choses,
l'observation,
les questions
avec cette personne,
à son entourage,
demander des conseils
auprès de frères
ou sœurs matures
dans la foi,
conseils auprès
des pasteurs,
etc.
Il y a beaucoup
de moyens
de faire ça.
Mais faire tous nos efforts
pour nous assurer
de l'authenticité
de la foi
de cette personne
pour être sûr
du mieux que l'on peut
et c'est possible
qu'il s'agit
d'un vrai chrétien
ou d'une vraie chrétienne.
Est-ce que cette personne
est un vrai chrétien
ou une vraie chrétienne ?
Pour faire encore plus court.
Deuxième point,
en s'assurant
que l'intérêt est réciproque,
c'est quand même mieux.
Et troisième point,
c'est tout.
C'est tout.
En tout cas,
c'est tout pour moi.
Voilà pour cette question
qui était un peu longue
mais je pense
que c'était important
ou intéressant
en tout cas
de revenir sur
à la fois
ce terme d'âme sœur
puisque c'était
finalement
ce qui était
dans le fond
de la question
et puis ensuite
de voir un peu
dans la pratique
comment les choses
s'appliquent.
Est-ce que vous voulez compléter
ou est-ce qu'il y aurait
des questions
suite à cette réponse ?
Une réflexion,
est-ce que ça répond à...
Oui, oui.
Voilà.
Ça s'applique
en fait à tout.
C'est-à-dire que
plutôt que d'essayer
de découvrir
la volonté décrétive de Dieu,
est-ce que Dieu veut
que je marche
dans ses plans éternels
dans cette direction ?
Plutôt réfléchir
avec la révélation
qu'il nous a donnée
donc les principes bibliques
sur qu'est-ce qu'un métier honorable,
qu'est-ce qu'un homme
doit chercher comme métier,
quelles sont ses responsabilités
déjà en tant qu'homme
et ça va certainement induire
certains...
Oui, ça induira des choix
notamment le choix
d'un métier honnête
avec un gain honnête,
un gain suffisant
pour lui et sa famille.
Tu vois ?
Il y a plein d'autres choses à dire
mais je pense
que c'est beaucoup plus comme ça
qu'il faut aborder les sujets
plutôt que de passer
un temps infini
parce qu'il sera infini
et on ne trouvera jamais la réponse.
Est-ce que c'est ça
la volonté décrétive de Dieu pour moi ?
Donc, dans un certain sens,
quand quelqu'un te dit
« chef, c'est que Dieu réalise pour toi,
c'est pas que tu dis ».
Voilà.
Ça dépend ce qu'il a en tête.
Exactement.
Ça dépend de quelle recherche tu fais.
Est-ce que c'est une recherche
miraculeuse
de la réponse divine
du décret de Dieu sur ta vie ?
Ou est-ce que,
comme l'art de la vie,
est-ce que c'est plutôt
une recherche active
selon les principes bibliques
pour raisonner avec la parole de Dieu
et rechercher dans la parole de Dieu
quelle est la volonté de Dieu ?
Parce que le Seigneur nous appelle
à avoir du discernement
pour reconnaître sa volonté.
C'est sa volonté
qui est explicité dans les lectures
par lesquelles on doit marcher
selon les principes de la parole de Dieu.
Je ne sais pas,
avoir une fenêtre ouverte
sur le ciel
pour que Dieu nous dise
ce qu'il avait prévu
avant la formation du monde.
Et dans certains cas,
ce qui se passe,
c'est que
c'est un peu comme
lorsqu'on aborde,
je veux,
pour comprendre le contexte,
par exemple,
quand on va parler
des femmes pasteurs,
la plupart vont toujours
prendre le même exemple.
On va aller chercher
des beaux rats
sans avoir étudié le contexte.
Là,
c'est la même chose.
C'est-à-dire que
souvent,
certains vont voir
« Ah,
mais Dieu s'était révélé
à Gédéon,
toutes ces choses. »
Mais une des choses
qui est remarquable
dans toutes les personnes
à qui Dieu s'est révélé,
c'est que
les personnes travaillaient.
C'était des personnes
qui étaient en train
de travailler.
Elles n'étaient pas
en train de paresser.
Non,
elles étaient en train de...
Ce qu'elles avaient
comme compétence,
elles étaient en train
de faire quelque chose
et Dieu les trouve
à ce moment.
Jamais Dieu n'a trouvé
quelqu'un qui était assis
paresseusement
l'après-midi.
Non.
Donc déjà,
une des choses aussi,
souvent même par rapport
à cet aspect,
quand il y a des gens
qui vont dire
« Je cherche le but
de Dieu pour ma vie »,
c'est déjà
d'être actifs
dans ce qu'ils ont
comme compétence
au niveau de l'Église.
Et Dieu peut...
Voilà,
après,
Dieu peut permettre
aussi de mieux trouver
les choses.
Et le dernier point,
parce que là encore,
c'est la même chose.
Beaucoup vont prendre
la révélation.
« Ah,
mais Abraham a envoyé
son serviteur,
il y a eu une façon
miraculeuse
par laquelle
Rebecca a été trouvée.
Là encore,
si nous lisons bien
la parole de Dieu,
nous voyons bien
que le serviteur
n'est pas dans ce dont
on vient de parler
une destinée.
Non.
Il vient,
il prie,
et dans les critères
qu'il est en train
de donner,
il donne des critères
où il est en train
de chercher une personne
qui a des qualifications
pour être une épouse.
Et il trouve une personne
qui a justement
en train,
quand Rebecca,
il trouve Rebecca,
il trouve quelqu'un
qui est en train
de servir,
et de faire les choses
de ce qui pourrait
être attendu
d'une épouse.
Et par la providence
de Dieu,
il s'est trouvé
que par rapport
aux recommandations,
parce que là encore,
par rapport à la foi
qu'Abraham plaçait en Dieu,
Abraham avait refusé
qu'Isaac épouse
des filles de ce pays,
mais dans son espérance,
dans sa grâce,
Dieu va permettre
que Rebecca soit justement
la fille de,
c'était son oncle,
de son oncle.
Mais voilà,
donc là,
l'exemple qu'on voit,
c'est aussi une démarche
que n'importe quelle personne
qui est dans le sens
du désir du mariage
va faire,
c'est-à-dire,
il va prier en disant
Seigneur,
je prie pour trouver
une personne
qui soit en train
de remplir ses critères,
je suis en train
et c'est dans ce sens,
et là,
ça complète
ce que Nat a dit.
Donc chaque fois,
c'est toujours important
de,
quand on a affaire
à des personnes
qui viennent toujours
avec cette espèce
de révélation,
de toujours leur rappeler
le contexte,
parce que souvent,
on extrapole beaucoup,
on sort beaucoup
les événements
de leur contexte.
Je voulais vous dire
que le cas pratique
que Nat a évoqué
vis-à-vis du mariage,
c'est vraiment quelque chose
qu'on rencontre beaucoup,
malheureusement.
Des personnes qui,
malgré la volonté révélée
dans la parole de Dieu
pour le choix d'un conjoint,
vont venir nous voir
en disant
oui, mais le Seigneur
m'a mis cette personne
sur la route,
ou le Seigneur m'a dit
que c'était pour elle,
pour son bien,
ou pour sa conversion future,
ou peu importe.
Donc,
ils se mettent un peu
à la place de Dieu lui-même
en surpassant la volonté
clairement explicité
dans la parole de Dieu,
en s'attachant
à une autre volonté
auxquelles ils n'ont même pas accès,
en disant voilà,
Dieu m'a dit,
et en disant ça,
en fait,
ils sont simplement
en train de dire
Dieu m'a dit
d'aller contre
sa propre volonté.
Donc,
voilà,
il faut vraiment faire
très attention
dans cette,
surtout sur ce sujet,
qui est difficile
quand nos sentiments
et nos émotions
sont impactés.
Est-ce qu'il y a d'autres questions ?
Sinon, je pense qu'on va s'arrêter là.
parce que
la troisième question
qui portait sur la différence
entre providence
et souveraineté de Dieu
et comment ne pas avoir peur
de la providence de Dieu
dans le sens,
comment gérer
dans la vie chrétienne
cette,
les épreuves,
la souffrance
ou l'appréhension de l'avenir
même,
en tant qu'être humain.
La réponse est longue
parce qu'elle doit l'être
un minimum.
Je n'ai pas envie
de la bâcler
et surtout,
David tenait aussi
à répondre à cette question.
Il a envoyé une réponse
qui est assez complète
et donc,
je préfère l'envoyer
par écrit
sur le groupe Signal
pour que vous puissiez lire
la réponse
plutôt que de la faire
assez vite
à l'oral
et je n'ai pas envie
de la faire
c'est des sujets
trop importants
pour le faire
de cette manière.
la réponse est là
mais je vais plutôt
vous l'envoyer par écrit.
après,
on peut répondre
de manière plus réduite
à la question
que j'avais gardée
en réserve
de ta part.
Tu peux la réexpliciter
un peu ?
Oui,
non,
ça me revient.
C'est,
oui.
Parfois,
il apparaît que,
si j'essaie
de simplifier un peu,
Dieu nous fait passer
par des épreuves
en tant que chrétiens
qui peuvent nous donner
l'impression
qu'on bénéficie moins
de la grâce commune
que même des non-chrétiens.
C'est ça,
non ?
Oui.
Et comment
comprendre ça
et comment le vivre
si on le vit ?
Alors,
en termes de quantité,
je ne sais pas
si je pourrais répondre
avec assurance
si entre quantité,
on a plus de tribulations
et de difficultés
que les inconvertis.
Est-ce que c'est une...
ça peut être le cas,
mais est-ce que c'est
une assurance biblique
que les chrétiens
ont quantitativement
plus de difficultés ?
Néanmoins,
il y a un type
de souffrance
et de difficultés
auxquelles les chrétiens
sont...
En tout cas,
tous ceux qui veulent vivre
dans la piété
vont rencontrer
que les inconvertis
ne rencontreraient pas.
C'est la persécution.
Donc,
la persécution
au nom de notre foi,
de notre profession de foi,
c'est une promesse
pour les chrétiens,
pour tous ceux
qui veulent vivre
dans la piété.
Et c'est une promesse
de Dieu pour eux.
Et c'est le lot
exclusivement réservé
aux vrais chrétiens.
Donc,
quelqu'un qui fait...
qui subit
une forme
de persécution
à cause
de sa profession de foi,
je ne sais pas,
par exemple,
pensez aux hindous,
aux musulmans
en Inde,
par exemple.
Ce n'est pas
la persécution biblique.
La vraie persécution biblique,
c'est la persécution
pure.
C'est contre
la vraie profession
de foi.
Donc,
c'est une persécution
profondément injuste.
Donc,
ce type de souffrance,
elle est le lot
exclusif
du chrétien
et le chrétien
est assuré
de rencontrer
ce type de persécution,
ce type de souffrance
dans sa vie.
Il se peut aussi
que,
de façon particulière
et spéciale,
le Seigneur
nous réserve
quelques difficultés
supplémentaires
dans la vie
de ses enfants.
Et tout cela
joue plutôt
pour notre bien.
Ce sont
des épreuves
ou même,
dans d'autres traductions,
des tests,
des tests
de notre foi
qui,
non seulement,
montrent
où est notre
véritable attachement,
mais qui nous apprennent
aussi,
de façon didactique,
à dépendre
du Dieu davantage.
Donc,
lorsque le Seigneur
nous donne des épreuves
à nous,
les chrétiens,
par exemple,
voilà,
un enfant qui est malade
ou une propre maladie
dans notre corps,
c'est une opportunité,
c'est ça qu'on doit dire
à notre âme
qui est facilement abattue
dès lors qu'on est devant
une épreuve.
Une épreuve,
comme un étudiant,
c'est un test,
c'est une opportunité
que Dieu nous donne
d'apprendre à dépendre
davantage de lui.
Donc,
l'épreuve,
pour le chrétien,
c'est une manifestation
de la bienveillance de Dieu.
C'est pour son bien.
C'est pour qu'il grandisse
en lui.
Et,
je dirais que le chrétien,
pour conclure,
a davantage de ressources
que l'inconverti
pour faire face
aux épreuves.
C'est même pas davantage,
c'est à des ressources
infinies
lorsqu'il fait face
aux épreuves.
Donc,
tu as parlé
de la grâce commune
qui permet quelque part
d'alléger,
et c'est vrai,
c'est une réalité,
qui permet quelque part
d'alléger les souffrances
auxquelles même
les inconvertis font face.
En revanche,
le chrétien,
lui,
il peut puiser
une ressource
qui est infinie
dans le temps des épreuves.
et les psaumes
sont là pour nous rappeler
un David
qui est un type du Christ,
qui est dans les tourments
les plus profonds,
dans une profondeur abyssale
de son âme,
mais qui trouve,
qui cherche le refuge
et qui trouve le refuge
en l'éternel.
Et systématiquement,
dans ce type de psaume,
on voit la résolution
de sa peine,
de ses craintes,
de ses afflictions,
dans la ressource ultime
qui est Dieu.
L'inconverti
n'aura jamais cet espoir,
jamais cette assurance,
et au-delà de la mort,
il n'a aucun espoir.
Le chrétien,
même si son affliction
le conduit même
à mourir,
qui est quelque part
l'expérience
la plus ultime
ici-bas sur Terre,
même pour lui,
c'est une délivrance.
Même le point
le plus abyssal
de la souffrance
qu'il peut connaître
ici-bas
va se résoudre
dans quelque chose
d'infiniment glorieux.
Voilà,
je voulais juste rappeler
ces trois points.
Un type de souffrance,
c'est vrai,
qu'on rencontre,
le Seigneur nous assiste
et nous apprend
à dépendre de lui,
donc c'est plutôt
un acte de bienveillance
pour nous,
les épreuves,
pour les chrétiens,
et on a des ressources
bien plus profondes
et qui nous donnent
la capacité
de soutenir.
C'est ce qu'on voit
dans Philippiens.
Philippiens,
la série de prédications,
c'est un homme
qui fait face aux souffrances,
qui est emprisonné,
qui est dans la solitude,
mais quelle est sa consolation
et quelle est sa capacité
de se maintenir
dans les épreuves ?
C'est l'excellence
de la connaissance
du Seigneur Jésus-Christ,
que les inconvertis n'ont pas.
de la connaissance,
c'est un homme,
Le lien que je verrai,
c'est que,
je m'attendais à ce que ça sonorise,
mais ça enregistre juste.
Certainement que Paul devait aborder
cette écharpe de cette manière,
c'est-à-dire que plusieurs fois,
il dit que pour lui,
sa plus grande joie,
son plus grand bien,
ce serait d'être déjà auprès de Christ,
mais il considère la mission
que Christ a encore pour lui,
ici-bas,
comme quelque chose
qu'il doit accomplir
et qu'il fait avec joie
dans l'attente de son retour.
Il devait certainement considérer
cette écharpe dans la chair
comme une épreuve
que Dieu utilisait
pour le préparer,
le former,
le faire progresser
en stature,
dans sa foi,
en maturité,
dans l'attente de ce jour
où il rejoindrait Christ.
Donc,
je n'ai pas tout le contexte
du verset en tête
pour te dire
s'il fait un lien direct
avec ce qu'on vient de dire,
mais en tout cas,
très clairement,
il y a quand même des liens à faire.
Il devait certainement
considérer
cette écharpe
comme une épreuve
que Dieu
décidait de maintenir
dans sa vie
puisqu'il,
je ne sais pas s'il demande
à Dieu de lui enlever,
mais il exprime en tout cas
la souffrance que c'est
et il devait certainement considérer
que tant que Dieu
lui laissait cette épreuve,
c'était dans ce but-là
que Loïc a bien expliqué.
Merci.
Malgré tout ce qu'il peut traverser.
Oui,
j'ai juste quelques rappels
rapides
par rapport à cette question.
C'est que Dieu
ne nous tente jamais
au-delà de nos forces.
Alors,
il faut comprendre
cette affirmation
à travers Christ,
évidemment,
parce que si c'était
juste nos forces
charnelles,
bien sûr que tout serait
au-delà
de nos forces
pour résister,
pour persévérer
dans la foi,
mais pour tout chrétien
qui est uni en Christ
et qui dispose
de la force
que donne le Saint-Esprit,
effectivement,
Dieu ne nous tente jamais
au-delà de nos forces
et il est dit aussi
que lorsqu'il nous éprouve,
il pourvoit aussi
les moyens
de sortir de l'épreuve.
Donc,
David a bien,
dans la réponse
qu'il a faite
à la question
qu'on ne traitera pas ce soir,
il a bien développé ça.
voilà,
Dieu n'a pas promis,
au contraire,
il a fait l'inverse.
Jésus n'a pas promis
à ses disciples
un avenir
plus facile que les autres,
sans maladie,
etc.
Alors,
éternellement,
oui,
mais sur terre,
il a promis l'inverse,
il a averti de l'inverse.
Vous serez persécutés
à cause de mon nom,
donc effectivement,
vous aurez des souffrances
spécifiques à vous,
mes disciples,
à cause de votre foi
de mon nom,
mais je serai avec vous.
Et il est mieux pour vous
que je remonte au ciel,
car mon Saint-Esprit,
bon,
il ne dit pas là
mon Saint-Esprit,
mais le Saint-Esprit
descend sur,
et habite en chaque chrétien,
et Christ est avec
chaque chrétien.
Donc,
Dieu a promis,
non pas qu'il nous éviterait
dans sa providence
toutes les épreuves,
mais qu'il serait toujours
avec nous,
et qu'il nous soutiendrait,
qu'il préserverait
notre foi,
pas forcément notre vie,
parce qu'on doit bien
mourir un jour,
mais notre foi,
et on sait ce qui se passe
de toute façon
après la mort.
Ça, par contre,
c'est certain.
Un autre point,
c'est que la discipline
de Dieu nous prouve
que nous sommes
ses enfants qu'il aime.
La discipline de Dieu,
c'est notamment
ses épreuves,
qui sont des outils
d'éducation,
que Dieu utilise
pour nous faire croître
dans notre foi,
comme je disais,
en stature,
et pour donner
l'exemple de Paul,
cette écharde
qu'il avait dans la chair
devait être
un de ces outils
que Dieu a décidé
d'utiliser
pour le faire progresser,
lui,
l'apôtre,
en stature
dans la foi.
Mais le point
qui est important
de retenir,
c'est que
nous souffrons,
oui,
de la même manière
que les autres
êtres humains
peuvent souffrir,
d'une manière particulière,
en plus,
en tant que chrétien,
selon la décision de Dieu
pour chacune de nos vies,
mais tout cela
a un sens différent
pour nous,
en tant que chrétien,
puisque nous le voyons
comme la discipline
d'un père
qui nous aime
et qui veut
nous faire grandir.
Tout cela n'est pas
vide de sens,
ce n'est pas le fruit
du hasard,
ce n'est pas inutile.
Toutes ces épreuves
sont des choses
que tu utilises
pour nous faire grandir.
Et dernier point
que je ne vais pas développer,
mais on a, oui,
des épreuves particulières,
peut-être,
même en plus grand nombre,
et plus dures
que soit d'autres chrétiens,
soit d'autres hommes
et femmes,
mais que dire
des bénédictions
qui nous attendent.
Elles aussi sont,
non pas supérieures,
mais la destinée éternelle,
pour le coup,
est beaucoup plus,
l'écart est beaucoup plus grand
entre les destinées éternelles
des élus et des perdus,
des vrais croyants
et des non-croyants,
que les écarts
de bénédictions
et d'épreuves
de leur vie sur terre.
Et c'est évidemment
une perspective
qui nous aide
quand Dieu décide
de nous éprouver
ici-bas.
Et c'est notamment
aussi pour ça
qu'il nous éprouve,
si nous avons tendance
à trop nous attacher
à cette vie ici-bas,
à ne pas assez regarder
à l'éternité
qui nous attend
et qui est déjà
notre citoyenneté aujourd'hui.
Dieu utilise
les épreuves
pour que nos regards
se portent plus,
plus profondément,
plus longuement,
de manière plus persistante
vers cette éternité
qui nous attend,
à laquelle on doit
aspirer
et nous préparer.
Merci.